well my friends we are getting
dangerously close to the 2022 midterm
elections debates are in full swing we
have multiple debates uh that I will be
live streaming this week and next week
and the week after and I want to start
today with three important races where
we have either a debate to talk about or
a public appearance or something we will
first talk about Texas governor which is
incumbent Republican Greg Abbott versus
Democratic Challenger Beto O'Rourke we
will then talk about Republican senator
from Florida Marco Rubio the incumbent
against the Challenger democratic
congresswoman Val demings who is uh uh
won the Democratic primaries and is now
facing Marco Rubio and then we will talk
about a very important race Pennsylvania
gubernatorial where the Democratic
candidate Josh Shapiro is facing off
against the Republican uh nominee of
Doug mastriano and mastriano is one of
the most dangerous and extreme
candidates and he is also cuckoo for
Coco Puffs but we will get to that let's
not get to the Cocoa Puffs right away
start with Greg Abbott we did a live
stream on YouTube tuition Facebook last
week of this debate the debate is the
incumbent Republican governor of Texas
Greg Abbott against the Challenger Beto
O'Rourke and we actually did learn a lot
about Greg Abbott during this debate
including uh undeniable confirmation
that Abbott is a completely disgusting
and a completely immoral and dishonest
person which is sort of like the
trifecta for republicans in 2022. let's
start with the first clip in this clip
you will see Greg Abbott when presented
with the reality about abortion in the
world he says listen you know we're
trying to get people baby supplies so
you don't really need access to abortion
when you've got baby supplies do you is
Plan B the alternative when it comes to
somebody who is pregnant from rape or
incest
well it depends on what you mean by
alternative an alternative obviously is
to do what we can to assist an aid uh
the victim and that is to help get them
medical assistance that they need and
the care that they need but also uh to
know what their options are they're
gonna to know that the state uh
throughout our alternatives to abortion
program provides living assistance baby
supplies all kinds of things that can
help them also we've increased funding
for prenatal and postpartum care thank
you listen guys if you are and I
shouldn't say guys because it's not guys
listen if you are in the situation where
uh you are raped by a family member and
you become pregnant sure you might think
that what you want is to decide for
yourself with the Council of medical
professionals that you might want to not
carry that pregnancy to term we have
this alternative where we will give you
baby supplies after you're forced to
birth the baby
this is Republicans in 2022 now they
deserve to suffer electoral losses as a
result of this complete and utter
Insanity whether they will is a
different question and I don't actually
know the answer right now also during
this very same debate Greg Abbott got
caught lying just straight up lying here
is Greg Abbott claiming he didn't
coordinate uh that uh rather he denies
that he didn't coordinate these
political stunts where they sent
immigrants to different uh
democratically run cities he just
straight up gets caught lying check this
out Governor I want to talk to you you
talked about uh migrants and the
blessing of migrants many migrant
Advocates and Democratic elected
officials have expressed concerns about
the treatment of migrants being bussed
from Texas to other states and cities
here's New York mayor Eric Adams talking
about that just last week yep and when
we reached out to Governor Abbott and
stated can we coordinate can we identify
you know who's traveling here that we
don't have to guess this they refuse to
do so
the White House has called this a
political stunt Governor Abbott is this
a political stunt and has there been
coordination with the states and cities
these migrants are being taken to and if
not why not you have 60 seconds so this
operation began after meeting with local
officials sheriffs understand how slick
that is he says we have coordinated we
we coordinated with local officials here
in Texas no no no no but Greg the issue
is
why didn't you coordinate with the
people in the cities where you were
sending the migrants he tries to slip
and no we spoke to all sorts of people
here in Texas police Chiefs and County
judges where they were overrun with the
number of migrants that border patrol
had dumped into to their tiny little
communities they needed relief and
busing was one of the ways of providing
them relief and thus began the process
of busting the magnets to cities that
self-identified as sanctuary cities
mayor Adams has never called my office
never talked to anybody uh in in my
Administration and that is a lie we now
have the receipts thankfully Fabian Levy
who is the press secretary to New York
City mayor Eric Adams published emails
with redacted email addresses where you
just very clearly very very clearly see
there are email chains we have one up on
the screen right now they did attempt to
communicate and it was Greg Abbott that
opted not to quickly proven to be a
complete and total lie Beto would have
uh quite frankly a very strong closing
statement and really puts significant
pressure on Abbott on the issue of doing
nothing about Firearms violence in Texas
we'll see you tonight 30 seconds for
your closing statement your time starts
now thank you look I don't think that
Greg Abbott wakes up wanting to see
children shot in their schools or for
the grid to fail but it's clear that
he's incapable or unwilling to make the
changes necessary to prioritize the
lives of our fellow Texans that's why
it's on all of us to make sure that we
have change at The Ballot Box this
November 8th I'll keep your lights on
I'll make sure that I keep your kids
safe we'll reduce property taxes and
we'll prioritize the lives of each and
every single Texan in the state all
right so by the way the debate was a
total disaster in terms of the format
there were times where the candidates
were given 15 seconds to respond to
something
it's you know it's one of these things
where the format becomes an enemy of
itself where in order to stick to this
arbitrary format they completely ruin
the possibility of any deep discussion
on any issue so the the unfortunately we
didn't really learn very much other than
confirming some of the horrible things
we uh suspected about Greg Abbott going
in now one interesting thing
KXAN out of Austin Texas did a focus
group before and after the debate and
they had them watch the debate
the debate itself turned a whole bunch
of that room in favor of Beto O'Rourke
so check this out this is the start and
you'll see them put up the numbers you
guys had a lot to say uh during during
the focus group we were able to track
your reactions in real time
um but before our debate this evening we
pulled you with a couple of questions
and one of the responses that we got we
want to share with you now we have a
Graphic to show you this is how you
voted if we as we okay so
um the way that the focus group voted
before the debate was 40 percent said
they plan to support Greg Abbott 27
percent said they plan to support Beto
and 33 percent were undecided I'm just
going to skip through the two minutes of
stuff that they talk about and just show
you these final results after the uh
debate the Abbott number was at 43
Beto had exploded to 50 support in the
room leaving only seven percent
undecided so that's the good news on the
this race the not so good news is that
the the polling in general isn't very
good for Beto but again the idea is the
debate might change that on average it
is Abbott plus eight looking at official
polling in that race so if you live in
Texas a very important race for you to
vote in
the David packman shows longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers I've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books I read I
love reading I I read all the time but
there's even more books I don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com davidpakman
the link is down below